et là on peut filmer et là et là là là
là je crois qu'on soul gary et la salue
aujourd'hui je suis à la valette-du-var
l'occasion d'un festival de magie où je
suis programmé et c'est à côté de toulon
la valette du var et il ya un monsieur
qui est venu me chercher à la gare c'est
jérôme leleu
il a une voix de pollution du raymond
barre jérôme leleu c'est quelqu'un que
j'ai rencontré ya quelques années parce
que tu t'occupes de fantaisie prod sur
une boîte de prod qui monta festival à
toulon enfin qui monte du moindre risque
il à toulon qui s'appelait les
toulonnaises et il m'a probante et
citronnade et fantaisie tous les
nogentais et oui tout à fait et il m'a
programmé à l'époque où je commençais
juste le spectacle a pris le risque de
me programmer pour diriger ce qui a
beaucoup d'argent et je m'étais bien
éclatés qui m'a fait revenir l'année
d'après doivent ok je suis maso
bah oui ok de le dire comme tu sais je
fais une vidéo par jour jérôme par jour
par jour viennent tous les jours tous
les jours est-ce que tu as regardé les
66 vidéo qui a déjà vraiment non je
pense que même ma mère les a pas
regardés par semaine regardera les 66
vidéo voilà eh bien j'espère que ça t'a
plu j'ai pas encore joué entre les deux
jouent ce soir j'ai pas dormi dans le
train puisque j'ai monté les vidéos
d'hier en fait dans le train mais hier
pour moi c'est aujourd'hui je le voyais
un peu parce que je réfléchisse à ce
qu'on va faire et je sais que moi dans
je ne sais pas du tout c'est alors vous
devrez toi tu sais pas du tout blanc
j'aimerais que tu penses à une ville
dans ta tête
n'importe quelle ville du monde une
ville pour lequel par intérêt ou une
grosse ville où un petit village tu as
peu importe ton choisi dans ta tête
est-ce que je peux prendre au téléphone
ça tue la déverrouiller ou pas oui vas-y
vas-y tu es vers ouled c'est bon ok on
peut se retrouver une fois hilton faut
toutefois c'est vrai que c'est tellement
ça tu n'as pas
safari je suis non ceci peut-être je
sais pas alors à temps
l'acide et la dent productivité il a
rangé safari dans productivité s'il vous
plaît alors là tu captes c'est un
téléphone au gaz pour ce corps sarah
mais laisse tomber je met comme ça que
vous voyez faire je me mette sur
maps.google.com comme ça on est sur
google maps ça va nous servir tout à
l'heure tu as tu eu une ville ou un
village en tête maintenant séverine pas
ok là c'est je te poses des questions tu
me répond par oui ou non dans ta tête
pendant quelques
c'est une grande ville oui c'est bien ça
me donne le premier impôt ok j'aimerais
qu'on parle ou pas redondant pas tu es
dans ta tête à toi ça ne doit pas passer
par la bouche
est ce que cette ville est en france
c'est dur un prêt pour me faire mal
est ce que cette ville je la connais
est-ce que d'après toi à sa charge par
la cps que d'après toi c'est une ville
où je suis allé oui peut-être
je sais pas mais me répond pas ça
pendant sa tête est ce que c'est une
ville où j'aurais pu passer en tournée
ce que potentiellement qui identifie des
zones où j'aurai plus jouer d'accord
mais qui venait de s'emparer
ok alors j'ai juste prendre ton poignet
ça s'appelle du cul berland 10 mhz et je
vais essayer de prendre ton foot et
surtout tes réactions micro musculaire
en même temps
lato la santé en ce moment du coup de la
tribune bon ok tu penses à la première
lettre de cette ville c'est une charge
pas mener des vingt dix pensent vraiment
a b c d e f g h i j k l mn au pq est
resté buts w x y z d'accord pense au
nombre de syllabes je te laisse conter
dans ta tête d'abord le nombre de
syllabes hockey et un pile 5 ça peut
être une syllabe de syllabes trois
syllabes quatre syllabes
je tente un coup je tente un coup et ma
foi on verra
t'aime maman
ok j'ai pointé sur une ville sur le
google maps
grégory fait voir leur dire j'ai pointé
sur une ville sur le google maps que je
vous ai fait voir je le fais voir à
personne je le pose ici on voit pas trop
la caméra ajouté que reculer là on est
dans le champ
c'est là où la pression monte alors que
ceux des villes parce que si ça marche
pas j'ai juste n'a pas publié la vidéo
mais j'ai pas envie de te décevoir ou
différemment d'ajouter un montage c'est
vrai mais je veux pas tu as faim surtout
que j'étais exceptionnelle sur vidéo
mais c'était magnifique
je me redresse il se redresse par
rapport à ce que je connais tous à par
rapport à la première lettre que je
pense avoir identifié le nombre de
syllabes que je pense avoir identifié et
toutes les infos que tu m'as donné
volontairement ou pas avant je pense que
j'ai bon est ce que tu peux nous dire et
le redire maintenant et me dire surtout
quelle ville de tavel choisi dans ta
tête
rio de janeiro rio de janeiro franck
téléphone retourne le délicatement effet
voir au téléphone sur quelle ville
j'avais fait pointer le google maps
je fais bien voir devant sur rio dé
janeiro
il n'a jamais réussi à compter les
syllabes dans sa tête monsieur wiggers
est incroyable peut-être que je trouve
en fait comme ça je ne fais que l'ex
préformateur
c'est la première fois qu'un directeur
de festival programmateur et c'est en
fait jérôme est super cool parce que sur
cette date là comme c'est dans son
secteur c'est à toulon il m'a accompagné
il m'a driver il m'a fait visiter un
super resto aller sur facebook et
rajouter fantaisie prod où il ya le site
internet aussi trouvé point fort d'y
répondre at il rajouté plutôt sur
facebook en ce moment vous
vous faites tourner aussi la fille de
francis cabrel et aurélie caouette
aurélie cabrel il m'a fait voir les
vidéos c'est assez bluffant fait je
m'attendais pas à ça un vrai univers
vraiment à l personnel et c'est hyper
intéressant abonnez-vous à la chaîne je
compte sur vous pour vous abonner
partager cette vidéo vous venez me voir
aux hallucinations collectives et
partout en france
merci beaucoup merci mon jérôme et
rendez vous demain à 17 heures pour le
prochain mentale blog ciao